senator cruz just grilled joe biden's
atf
nominee the bureau of alcohol tobacco
and firearms
three of my absolute favorite things
that come under heavy scrutiny from the
federal government
the atf nominee admitted he want he
wants to ban the most popular
rifle in america the ar-15 is
one of if not the most popular rifle in
america it's not a machine gun
it's a rifle your public position
is that you want to ban ar-15s is that
correct
senator uh thank you for the question
and
thank you for our visit yesterday and
offering me a dr pepper
it made me reminisce about my time in
central texas but now to your uh
question uh with respect to the ar-15
on i support a ban as
um as has been presented in
a senate bill and supported by the
president
the ar-15 is a gun i was issued on atf's
swat team and it's a particularly lethal
weapon
um and regulating it as other
particularly lethal weapons
um i have advocated for
as atf director if i'm confirmed i would
simply enforce the laws on the books and
right now
there is no such ban on those guns
so you want to ban the most popular
rifle in america
you gotta love senator cruz here this
guy
is so good at being a senator he i don't
just say it
because we host the show together i
don't just say because he's a friend of
mine he's really good
the the biden atf nominee he's trying to
do that washington thing he's trying to
really you know present himself as
totally above board guy he's flattering
ted cruz he's
creating rapport he says so hey hey atf
nominee you you want to ban the most
popular rifle in america he goes
senator i just want to begin thank you
for uh thanks for giving me that diet
coke
or whatever dr pepper oh yeah that
brought me back that doctor i love dr
pepper
yeah that's great that was i had a great
time with you yesterday senator
so yeah you know i look i think i would
want to ban the gun but you know look
there'd be laws and this and that
cruz just doesn't even move he just goes
yeah okay so
you want to ban the most popular gun in
america is that right
well uh oh yeah yes cass you can't get
around that
he does and credit to this atf nominee
i'm sure he couldn't hide it i'm sure
there were public statements to this
effect
but he comes out and he says yeah i do i
want to ban
the most popular rifle in america
that cuts to the heart of our democracy
that cuts to
the heart of our civil rights it's one
of the most important civil rights in
our country
the ability to keep and bear arms and
we're not even talking about some fully
automatic weapon we're not talking about
pistols which are used in a whole lot of
crime
we're talking about rifles which are
used in relatively very few crimes
specifically that ar15 hey stop before
you go
just one second subscribe ring the bell
like it subscribe head on over by the
way to apple podcast google play spotify
wherever you get your podcasts
subscribe leave a five-star review i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna give you all
sermon about it
okay i'm not gonna go for hours and
hours it's very simple
do that and you will get the
notifications when we have more content
out there
see them
[Music]
[Music]